[Music]
Rachel she's still a kid you don't
embarrass that's going on you're gonna
explode dick stop you got problems I
think can remove whatever is inside you
you don't want to see what I really have
hey everybody its charlie we got brand
new Titans to break down Batman
flashbacks and a Doom Patrol trailer for
the next episode of Titans so I'll talk
about the Batman flashback stuff first
then I'll talk about Doom Patrol there's
a new round of the giveaway for the DC
streaming service all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I name a new winner
at the end of this so obviously the big
thing about that Batman flashback is
that you get to see Wayne Manor he walks
through he gets to see his room it's
crazy
remember this is happening right after
the events of that last flashback they
literally go right from the scene of the
crime to the police station with him
talking to this case worker here when
Bruce Wayne says I want to adopt him
obviously he's a billionaire so he fast
tracks that adoption they go straight to
Wayne Manor as you can see they're using
a very different looking building this
is the Toronto area where they film this
show so that's why all the buildings
look different because the Queen mansion
on the arrow series is just the same
exterior from Lex Luthor's mansion
during the Smallville series it's just a
really recognizable piece of
architecture so of course they're gonna
pick a really cool building to double as
a really famous family's mansion you get
a little bit of Alfred then obviously he
runs away showing his acrobatic skills
as he tries to escape with Batman
watching from a distance like just sort
of keeping his eye on him because
there's no Batman voice over during a
lot of these scenes you don't know
exactly what's going on in his head but
you can see the wheels turning like oh
he's like me he's seeking vengeance he's
going around looking for the people that
killed his parents like that's why he
explains he stole the Porsche like he
goes into this little Joyride has a
little bit of fun Bruce Wayne obviously
not gonna press charges against him
instead realizes what's going on without
Robin having to tell him and then gives
him the letter there's a better way let
me teach you how to channel your anger
so the thing you may have noticed since
episode 1 is
every time we do a Robin flashback to
his origin story we get a little bit
more of Bruce Wayne
this time we're leaning into Batman you
see him from behind like flow on an
actor in a frame in a scene playing the
Bruce Wayne character then you see him
in the doorway you can actually even see
the pictures of them in the background
of the Wayne Manor here so this is what
Bruce Wayne Martha and Thomas Wayne
looked like on the show but he's
obviously a little kid in these pictures
so you don't know what adult Batman
looks like quite yet but it just seems
like they're slowly giving us more and
more until hopefully by the end of the
series we'll get to see him full-on in a
Batman suit but I haven't seen the final
episode so I can't say whether or not
they actually do that we'll just have to
wait and find out we did find out that
there's actually only 11 episodes in
season 1 I don't know why it's an odd
number I think there was supposed to be
12 originally for whatever reason they
decided to cut it maybe they want to
premiere Young Justice season 3 a little
bit earlier because the finale will now
be around the middle of December and I
think within a week or two of that Young
Justice season 3 is supposed to premiere
during the episode you actually get to
see Dick Grayson using some more Wayne
tech like he pulls at the scanner device
that connects him to a satellite is
basically like a Batman version of an
iPad that connects to special
proprietary Wayne tech the team comes
together you get to see Beast Boy join
up with him for the first time but they
haven't really quite gelled yet and
Robin gets to see what Starfire's lair
looks like in this giant scatter board
of evidence that she's been collecting
trying to track down Raven she suffered
some memory loss so she has no idea who
she is she doesn't know about this
writing obviously this is all about this
prophecy of Trigon entering our reality
through Ravens character so that's what
all the Bible verses all these imagery
of the Ravens is all about so Starfire
an ancient being princess of her
homeworld probably heard about the
prophecy that's probably why she came to
Planet Earth they've actually clarified
why her costume looks like this at the
beginning they said that she's
undercover and that was why she was with
Constantine Kovar she roasted him during
that first episode everybody gets more a
comic book II version of their costumes
but this is the first episode where
you've really seen them all come
together they're not on the same page
yet they haven't had that moment where
they all kind of show each other their
quirks this is my special power
everybody check it out you get to see a
little bit more of Starfire's power when
she
roasts the nuclear man they go back to
their home base and in the credits this
person is just credited as man in suit
like they're literally not telling you
who he is I think to prevent you from
finding out about what's going on with
this Trigon argh but there are really
only two big organizations that the Teen
Titans go up against in those early
comics one is hive the other is the
Church of blood in brother blood via the
Trigon storyline so that's why I think
this is all tied together I'm not
expecting them to get into hive stuff
during season one maybe tease that
organization because they did say they
would do a version of Deathstroke at
some point with Jericho and Grant Wilson
then they can do Judas contract and all
the Deathstroke specific storyline the
trailer for next week's episode
introduces the Doom Patrol but it's also
dealing with the aftermath of Ravens
demon self breaking her out of that
underground church so she just goes on a
tear the Doom Patrol looks like they're
trying to help her get rid of that demon
obviously it goes completely off the
rails Beast Boy is sort of the intro to
their group and they've already been
shooting the Doom Patrol TV show they've
recast a couple of the actors so the
people that you see during this won't
necessarily be the actors that you see
playing those characters during the
spin-off series but just to be clear it
is a spin-off of titans those shows will
crossover the Doom Patrol TV show will
introduce the cyborg character into this
Titans universe negative Man is the one
operating on Raven trying to get the
demon out of her he's the one that also
says you don't want to see my true self
he's talking about the energy for me can
project from himself
this is Elastigirl I'm guessing she's
all messed up looking here because of
the way her power works in the backfire
that happens when they try to mess with
Raven obviously you can see this as
robot man brendan fraiser is gonna be
doing the voice for him on the spinoff
series so just a picture Brendan
Fraser's voice coming out of his body
don't forget that they're getting ready
to set up Jason Todd but I think he's
episode 7 so he's still a couple weeks
away and Geoff Johns did say way back at
comic-con that there were some really
cool Dick Grayson scenes or the
flashback scenes with him in the Batcave
the other really cool thing that just
happened is is we found out that a bunch
of the classic speedster villains are
coming back for the flash 100th episode
later this year so I'll do a video for
that this weekend it's going to be crazy
congratulate
Timm adzick you're the giveaway winner
for my last big DC video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details click here for
my new flash trailer video and click
here for my Teen Titans Season 6 trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight